good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is sunny for the
first time in New York in one week the
Sun has come out if you're watching live
and you're like oh my god it's cloudy
having stroke no she's literally
something blew into her eye the second
the stream started pink oh my god stop
that's like my worst nightmare
pink eye is the worst thing you could
possibly contract like second to
coronavirus right we're like an STD I
actually think of all the things you
could contract pink guy's not that bad
I think I'd rather have an STD then pick
guys yeah well you're on your own like
at least an STD is like private and like
you deal with it like a pink eye is
right there right no you take up you
take off from work how come it was so
common when we were kids just because
like kids are disgusting yeah we're just
like farting on each other's pillow yeah
I'm like wiping our asses and touching
our ha well I have pink eyes so thanks
everyone for watching today I hope you
don't get it from the YouTube stream
we've got a busy busy show you know did
you watch Vanderpump rules
I watched Vanderpump rules I also
watched last night make millions have
you been hearing about this documentary
literally only from you yeah because
I've been seeing posters for it and the
branding anything with McDonald's I
believe is a winner is a winner so I
started to watch it it's an HBO
documentary about do you remember in the
90s if I think I barely remember what in
but like McDonald's used to run yeah
this huge Monopoly game in their
restaurants I thought it was a Monopoly
board that was like McDonald's branded
but no it was like a worldwide thing
where you got all these you peeled off
the cup yeah I actually remember that so
it turns out that in all of the 11 years
that this program ran every single
winner was actually related to one
another and it was illegitimate and
there was this whole scheme being how
much money do they win like hundreds of
millions of dollars yet so the
documentary
goes through the FBI investigation about
what happened that's interesting is it a
series or just movie takes part series
but there's only two parts out so I wish
I hadn't started it because I'm a binge
watcher in the age of Netflix you can't
you can't put out a documentary that I
have to wait week to week it's a
marketing thing like they like my mom
they have released the first episode of
Glee like six months before the season
and everyone was singing do-do-do-do-do
don't stop believing they do it to get
people excited
no and it's episodic it's not like they
it's like next week one comes out that
we'll see why they released two in the
beginning no they released one last week
one this week oh so this is a regular TV
show six-part series that's not about I
don't know documentaries I want to get
the answers in one city that was like
the jinx that HBO did it was a six-part
series also I couldn't get through the
first three parts it was so dense
HBO needs to like get off the series
like yeah I'm the age of binge watching
also like with the jinx thing the Robert
Durst story that was like one of those
famous crimes that like there were too
many like movies made about it like by
the end by the HBO documentary I'm sure
it was good but like I hadn't seen
enough about it I watched her on Gosling
movie I watch the other documentary man
go Lea whatever like I saw it all proud
to say I never saw one what oh my god
that Robert sure story was actually
super crazy
that's also what happened with Ted Bundy
it's like all of a sudden we were
inundated with ten Bundy stories that's
also what happened with Snow White
remember they made snow white at the
Huntsman at the same time allure as the
same time they made Mirror Mirror that
was weird it's weird it's like we have
hundreds of thousands of years on this
earth yeah we're gonna release to snow
white movies the same year very strange
but when it comes to certain crimes some
of them get beaten to a pulp that it's
like we don't need another documentary
on Ted Bundy you know yeah no matter
which celebrities playing Ted Bundy I
don't need another movie except that the
jinx was incredible because they got him
to admit on camera to what he did right
and it was like a series of events
brother I never got to that point
because it was so boring yeah that's
also like Oh Jay Simpson has now been
beaten to a pulp and I watched the 30
for 30 series and it was so boring like
at least the Ryan Murphy one was like
sexy and you know celebrities John
Travolta like the Kardashians oh my god
this 34:31 was so boring like me and my
robe literally fell asleep watching it
it was so so boring I think I watched
that one I don't know Oh Jay was just
like such a cultural phenomenon that I
don't think it can be ever spoken about
too much because it was like so
pervasive yeah but I need a break for
sure I mean I could always go for some
more Jon Benet especially if they feel
once they capture someone saying that
they did it there hasn't been like a
dramatized version of Jon Benet where
like you know where Jacob Tremblay you
know please JonBenet's best friend or
something you know like there hasn't
been that yet but I very much am looking
forward to that possibly happening I
think they wouldn't do that until they
know what happens until we can cry
because then they have to take a like a
stance on who they thought it was yeah
who would play Jon Benet though
J maybe G Giudice is that we gonna say
play in a way yeah no I was actually
thinking like which young blonde Ken and
all I could think was Jacob Tremblay
when I was trying to make the joke but I
think that's it
like do you member um Susie salmon the
lovely bones
yeah saoirse ronan is iconic girl people
like you know love turn Brooklyn they
loved her in Little Women but like I
loved her first and in The Lovely Bones
which was a book right yeah it'd be good
for your book club that was actually a
[ __ ] amazing movie and he Stanley
Tucci played the kidnapper
yeah weirder when I sat next him on the
plane I was like I'm talking to him
about it
Chuckie never sat next to Stanley Tucci
played but she did set is that next to
family Fucci no you know I think I might
have been sitting next to just a regular
bald man no the guy from the Kingsmen
who sings John Denver the bald guy
Galahad Chucky you satin like even know
whether well Stanley Tucci I think it
sat next to him Tenley - jeez I think I
sat next to him Jackie you sat next to a
bald man like I hate to break it to you
man with glasses after the Oscars I
don't know in coach it was an omen that
so funny okay I'll let you live in your
fantasy Lennox assembly see I really do
think I sat next to Galahad no you
didn't but by the way that character was
iconic in the second Kingsman iconic I
love the Kings but I can't wait for the
next one to come out I can't believe I
lived like five years like or however
the movie long had since been since the
movie came out like without like knowing
that I am like so into spy movies yeah
the Kings Inn is so good both of them
and I just loved her and I Girton love
love and I love Piers Morgan that's not
Pierce Morgan it's amanda Bynes his dad
from what a girl wants you grant no the
Colin Firth okay not only confuse that
with Colin Farrell not to be confused at
all both oh look like Piers Morgan
anyway okay it's also dear toaster so
we'll recap better pearls then we'll
jump to dear toasters which is our
advice segment and we are looking for
more submissions so email us dear
toasters at gmail.com try and keep it
interesting you know keep it fun keep it
light will always keep it anonymous
dear toasters at gmail.com love it sign
on get advice okay well I think it's
time to get into the fast sized stories
that you yes you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and that's definitely true
and you know why Jackie
I have nothing to say about that you're
for the first time in your career you
are right no I was I was right like back
in the day before we had at before
anyone wanted to work with us yeah but
no Jackie you're totally right it is
time I have for the first time in my
life I am you're still do each leg we
actually have a great batch of stories
today love to hear it's not every day
you get a great batch of story it's not
every day that is for sure the damn
truth hmm what do we do yesterday oh my
god we were so busy yesterday was a busy
say my feet yeah meetings meetings
meetings we're such bloggers with our
meetings I did a workout yesterday that
was just so hard
I'm sorry yeah me too and but I do feel
better about it today
speaking of workout actually a great
call about an upcoming project I hate to
be so annoying but the toasters are
gonna be so excited about it and I'm
really excited about it and I know it's
like speaking in tongues but it's
annoying could you say it's a secret
project yeah I I don't want to you know
would you say it's a special project no
I would say it's a secret project and I
think the only people who could ever
figure it out if they wanted to it would
be the Kingsmen they have their entire
agency all right the Statesmen they're
pretty you know I'll do a little
charades okay you know me it's so hard
for me to work on hi I'd like three
things right now I just want to scream
from the rooftops but I won't okay
first story justice Millette has been
indicted in Chicago over allegedly
staged 2019 attack who Mussie Smollett
oh yeah I remember him he was on Empire
write musty smell at on Tuesday was once
again indicted for allegedly staging a
hate crime attack against himself nearly
a year after charges in the case were
abruptly dropped if you are new here to
the toaster fandom I suggest that maybe
you after this episode go back and watch
our episode when this whole Jesse thing
was happening because why not [ __ ]
crazy we really we really highlighted
how the story was so weird made it even
weirder by the fact that his name is not
Jesse and that his name should actually
be Musti instead of Jesse because he's
the mushy ass [ __ ] I know yeah or you
know the French call him just just says
small ei this has been like the weirdest
series of events because he was like the
victim and then he was the criminal then
they just dropped it and then they
picked it and now it's back up
later and now he's indicted and I'm not
mad about it I just think the timeline
of events is incredibly weird I don't
know how the justice system works but it
just seems like I wouldn't guess it
works this way yeah
Cook County special prosecutor Dan Webb
revealed the former Empire star had been
hit with six new counts of disorderly
conduct
accusing Smollett of lying to the
Chicago Police Department about the
January 2019 incident Webb's
investigation revealed that Smollett
quote planned and participated in a
staged crime attack and then quote made
numerous false statements reporting a
heinous crime that he in fact knew had
not occurred Webb said in a news release
I mean that was the weirdest thing ever
and when they think about this crime
it's like well there's no victim like
it's it technically is a victimless
crime it's like when you think about all
the resources that the police Chicago
Police Department was putting into this
like high-profile investigation and that
very CUTE had sheriff you know who got
on this TV every every morning to talk
about the case I just justice for him
that's who I want justice for yeah the
crime was against the police departments
time and resources and the intelligence
and taxpayer money I mean when you come
for the taxpayers we have no choice but
to fight back ya know like I technically
am a victim I'm the jessee's smelly I
cuz I'm a taxpaying citizen even though
I don't live in Chicago I'm still a
taxpayer yeah we're all victims in this
crime we should all riot in the streets
okay this was just the craziest story
ever I can't believe it's back in the
headline I know you know what I kind of
missed it is that like [ __ ] up to say
it was so funny to report on because
like the series of events was so strange
like this thing happened and we reported
and everyone had like the same tone in
their voice about how horrible this act
was and like the real story that he was
was was telling everyone was so
unimaginably horrible like the hate
crime and it was just it was a sad day
for everyone it was just a rollercoaster
of emotions but because I think everyone
had like a little something in their
head but no one was gonna be the first
person to say it um I didn't know like I
know and not that I didn't want to say I
had no clue know all the reporters all
the reporters knew something was wrong
but nobody wants to be the first person
so it never crossed my mind that that
someone could make a bridge from such
like a somber sad
please to like a shocking place and now
it's like a joking place it's a joke
it's it's crazy also if you're new here
to the toast and you haven't seen Dave
Chappelle special where he talks about
as you say Smalley a it is one of the
funniest things ever and I really think
you should go watch it yeah
French Camp Red Lobster say sommelier
well French camper is also very much
looking forward to justice being served
she's always looking forward to justice
being served and in case you're new here
I don't know why I'm actually like we
have a million new subscribers I just
feel like we haven't done a recap like I
like to talk to the toasters as if
they're all new here but even though I
know they're not I must be really
frustrating to the people who actually
know totally but if you're whatever I
don't remember this way justice being
served no I was gonna explain um what do
we say repair camper no I'll explain her
so one time I was okay are you ready for
our next story because Macaulay Culkin
is back in the news with this Esquire
article thank you I thought it was house
fire also humming he goes by Mac now did
you see that no I didn't Culkin it's on
the cover top left Vulcan McCune yeah he
wants to be known as Mac and I have no
choice but to respect that okay
McCulloch I'm sorry Mac Culkin and and
brenda song are trying to have a baby
now I just needed this to remind
everyone that Mac Culkin and brenda song
are dating and we just can never forget
Jackie I needed absolutely no reminder
do you want to know why did you know
that I hung out with them at the WWE
summerslam this yes sound familiar
Ben and I got invited to the WWE
summerslam which is not really anything
I would normally go to but Ben really
wanted to go was at Barclays Center and
they were offering you know like the VIP
experience and I was like that's cool
we got to go behind the backstage trying
all like the costumes it was cool and
then there was like a little green room
for like celebs of WWE which I guess
included me and in walks Macaulay Culkin
and Brenda song and I like wasn't sure
who to be more shook over london tipton
or Kevin McCallister so I think I was
more shook at london tipton she really
shaped me as a woman back in the day so
I did know that they work together and
this is not shocking but I do feel sad
for Trace Cyrus brenda songs once your
love and I do feel bad for Mila Kunis
Macaulay Culkin's one true love they
used to do yeah what a weird couple
big-time odd couple um I kind of ship
these two I just watched doll face and
Brenda song is every
the sort knit and I love the cheese back
on the scene and she's also in a that
thriller movie on Netflix that people
love oh yeah where her husband like her
fake husband brings her home from the
coma and like then she remembers that
it's not her husband oh I heard it was
horrible and a BuzzFeed article did but
he did a hilarious article pointing out
all the inconsistencies in the plot it
was so funny that's the best part of the
movie that sounds really good I don't
watch scary movies but maybe I would I
don't watch scary movies
interesting factoid in this article is
that his brother Macaulay Culkin's
brother is in succession and now that I
told you that do you know exactly who he
is do you think I watch it you don't
have to even watch this I seem to know
that patch know I've literally never
seen a single person he's not gonna be
in succession and I would have no idea
no Claud you've seen this fotch never
gonna show you I'm sure he does other
stuff too oh my god yeah of course
that'll work out the Brotherhood yeah
and now you know exactly why they're the
same Koch oh my god totally was he in
secondhand lions also a great movie hold
on I'll find out what no he that's
that's the other Oh Haley Joel Osment I
get him confused with Macaulay Culkin
like young child stars secondhand lions
is such a beautiful movie like I cry
every time I see it oh I feel like he
was oh my god he's the brother and she's
all that he's the brother and she's all
that
yeah brother in she's all that the
Culkin family Hollywood royalty look at
all these credits back to him and Brenda
song I'm I just want to say I really
respect a Hollywood couple that just
like stays together very quietly for
long periods of time you know that's how
you know it's real like when they're not
like shoving your their relationship in
your face totally and the more like
shoved a relationship is in your face to
me the less of validity that it has and
that's all I have to say about that um
there's something I didn't choose as a
story because it's not really news yet
but you saw that ariana grande was like
making out with a blurry photo for
making out with someone in a bar in
Florida or something yeah in California
whatever um but then I got a rumor that
it's Jim Carrey excuse me yeah and
apparently like that's what the blinds
have been saying the toasters like said
that they think it's Jim Carrey Betty
and I googled Ariana Grande Jim Carrey
had just worked together and they were
raving about each other and now like
thinking that they might be hooking up
like it all it like makes sense wait
okay just pause for five sorry Ani
ariana grande popstar I
did this is not like blowing my mind
because I just saw a picture of them he
is like a kids show or something like a
weird cartoon something and she just did
like a cameo on it so I didn't know that
they had been like in the same room and
like she loves him you know she is such
weird taste in men that like this
doesn't surprise me on it oh and you
remember his last girlfriend very very
sad she ended up committing suicide was
very young he loves a young woman so
this is like I kind of shape I don't
know like it's just gross because like
he's so old and she's so young but like
I don't know it's it's kind of cold like
Ariana Grande could have any man in the
world like literally athlete popstar
rapper like she could have anyone no
matter how rich how poor how hot how
tall are short and she chose Jim Carrey
like the funny guy here's the thing it's
unfounded this is very alleged and it
might not be true but we would make this
up no totally now I need to take a
better look at the picture even though I
was so glad video you really couldn't
see that it was him um at all there was
nothing that makes me think it's him
other than the fact that I read it in a
comment no but now like now that you
told me it was that comfort it's 100%
true yeah I feel like that's so Ari vibe
no totally she has literally the worst
taste in man no no strange it's strange
strange and she obviously likes a funny
guy she like no and you know what she
like makes like not conventionally hot
guys hot like no one really thought P
Davidson was that hot until I'm Jim
Carrey the only reason why I think this
is like so crazy because if it was like
a woman of course man and the roles were
reversed like we would not be saying
this is cute so to be fair really I
think that when it comes to age like I'm
totally impartial like I think like
Samantha and Smith Jerrod is so cute and
I think if it was reversed I love that
too but like we can't get over Sophia
Richie and Scott Disick really way but
we love them we love them but every time
we say we love them we have to say the
age difference and so I love Jim Carrey
and Ariana Grande and I will mention the
age difference any time we talk about
them in the future okay I think that's
fair I think I totally impartial when it
comes like Cougars verse bachelors okay
I would love I would love to be
impartial
sorry Heidi hasn't caught up with me
like a modern woman but I think
personally when I speak on age like
relationships with huge disparities in
age I speak about it the same whether
the older person is the man or the woman
I would love to get to a place where
this show is aged blind
yeah just like Shark Tank and we just
know they are very age aware no I don't
see age I don't
and I mean you've seen my chick talk I
don't see age okay people were leaving
the meanest comments on my tech-talk
last night stick to Instagram like CEO
of being late to trends likes oh man Oh
could I put a video up of that Rachel
song which I love I just haven't this is
for Rachel you big fat white nasty
smelling fat [ __ ] why you took me off
the [ __ ] schedule with your
trifling dirty white racist ass big fat
[ __ ] Oompa Loompa body yes [ __ ] I'm
coming up there and I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you [ __ ] um it's like it
was this voicemail that went viral woman
I remember when people were like dancing
to voicemail
yeah so this this girl left a voicemail
for Rachel who allegedly took her off
the schedule and left this like really
nasty scathing message and someone turns
it into a song like they put a beat
behind it it's actually a banger like if
they ever played it in a club I'd be
like this is for facial you big [ __ ]
maybe it's like an old trend for the
youngsters but for the oldster it's like
me I'm just it sounds a little bit
familiar but it's not over to me yet so
I feel like you're really like bringing
in a new wave of awe yeah that's why
they hate me yeah
what were we talking Joe Perry ariana
grande Hulme carries also just like an
interesting felon
he is my favorite comedian growing up I
really love him I want happiness for him
I loved his episode of comedians in cars
getting coffee me too and I won't have
his Ferrari and like I really have no
choice but to ship know call me crazy
like I don't think it's that weird even
though like if you had told me like
hypothetically these two people would
maybe allegedly be getting together like
you would think it's so weird but I
don't know I think it's kind of cute
yeah I like them both so much
me too Jim Carrey seems dark though the
kids demons but all comedians do re
right anyways I think I think you for
sharing that rumor with me I hadn't
heard that and I love like an unfounded
like random rumor that never never ends
up being true but we could like
hypothesize about what it would be like
if ariana grande and Jim Carrey didn't
date for just a minute you know that
Justin but it could happen like I never
thought she would be with Pete Davidson
ever yeah but like it's not that crazy
like their age appropriately when I
heard it I was like oh this isn't true
believe Jim Carrey quicker than I
believed Pete Davidson she just has such
an eclectic taste in men that like this
doesn't surprise me like you could tell
me she was dating like you know pee-wee
Herman and I would be like so cute you
know
I just don't think it's that weird um
okay well next story switching gears a
little bit Kobe Bryant and his daughter
Gianna have been laid to rest two weeks
after the tragic helicopter crash oh I
thought they were gonna like tell about
it or something
certain like high-profile celebrities
have like televised Aretha Franklin when
Ariana Grande's saying they have like
big it's because so many people were
like more a part of it yeah I thought
they might do something like that
no the NBA legend and his 13 year old
daughter Evan laid to rest enews can
confirm the private Los Angeles funeral
comes just two weeks after the pair
along with other passengers tragic and
pilot tragically passed away in a
helicopter crash though the ceremony was
held privately a public memorial will be
held on February 24th at the Staples
Center in downtown LA gatta giving fans
an opportunity to pay their respects
quote we are one city that believes in
each other believes in something bigger
than ourselves the mayor said we will
absolutely do everything to make sure
that this is done so that everybody can
come to it as well that's really nice um
I'm so glad that this was private and
that so far I haven't seen any paparazzi
pictures like when paparazzi goes go to
funerals I think it's the most
inappropriate thing like I'll never get
over those pictures of Bethenny crying
when at the burial site for Dennis like
have some [ __ ] respect
is there no line in journalism none so
I'm glad that it was private I'm
actually like I know it's like weird to
say but I'm like living for Vanessa
Bryant like really being so public about
her grief like she's posted a lot on
Instagram long captions about how she's
struggling she like can't even begin to
mourn Cobie she doesn't even realize
that he's gone because all she can focus
on the fact is that her daughter's not
here and she's like and I feel so bad
because I'm not giving proper mourning
but she's like I know that's just a part
of grief she's just being like so open
about it which i think is really cool
yeah i I think it's it's nice and I'm
glad she's able to to like to process
yeah it just continues to be like the
craziest saddest story like I don't know
if I'll ever get over it now I don't
think you're ever supposed to I think
it's one of those things that you'll
always think about I don't just make you
think about life differently yeah and
like make you really realize there are
certain things that make you realize
like life is so short yeah and like
really anyone could die at any moment
like you could they always say like you
know well you smoke cigarettes but I can
also get hit by a car but like you
actually could actually get hit by a car
it's like in Jessica Simpson's book
which I did start last night so I would
absolutely adore if you could stop
spoiling it really yes so no because I
reading and like I read one thing that
you had mention and I'm like oh you know
what I would have loved to have read
that with a fresh mind
I don't remember something interesting
about an around cuz the beginning is all
about her childhood no it's in the just
in the intro like it's really it was
like a small thing but you would ruin it
and you're making me not want to read it
so if you could just stop fine well if
you could speed it up so we could do a
recap party of one is such a good song
such a good song I love her so much I
just like can't believe how connected I
was to Jessica Simpson as a child and
literally forgot about her for the last
ten years like I feel bad but I feel
like she wanted us to forget about her
in my part as a good fan she did it
she's such an anomaly to me I know and
like I just wanted to know what the
inside of our house looks like I'm dying
to know yeah I'm sure it's beautiful I
know she's so wealthy and she's like so
still so like southern witch like she's
lived in LA now for like 30 years and it
hasn't changed
still herself like even in her book you
know the way that she speaks it's like
she's still the same that same girl yeah
I like that
okay next story it's what they say about
us like they're like the biggest
podcasters in the world but there's
still just those regular Jewish girls
from Long Island I hope that they say
about us like oh my god they've burned
so much they don't even say like anymore
even though I got a bunch of messages
about the hypocrisy of us talking about
how frequently they were using the word
like on The Bachelor yesterday when
apparently yesterday's episode it was
riddled with likes from us okay anymore
I talk to you all the time and yes we
say like in conversation just like
anyone our age does the level that it
was on The Bachelor is not comparable
acrid Jackie it's not it's on a
different level tell them I'm not saying
that we're perfect we're not even good
to go we're not a bachelor level tell um
okay um have we need to give it up okay
oh and they're edited we're right
imagine me like say cut out cuz they
know how torturous it is right according
to Jimmy Kimmel yeah Monday night's
episode of The Bachelor had like 229
times which honestly and I think was so
bad no that's not a lot imagine how many
they cut out right in full conversation
how many left on the cutting room floor
exactly I don't think we've given a
programming update that we are not going
to be live tomorrow or Monday we're not
live tomorrow I'm sorry say sorry Friday
no show Friday Monday because we are
taking a long weekend for Valentine's
Day slash my Hanover's
slash beds gonna ask when with his
friend so I'm littering home alone and
keep a third DL our trip honestly yeah
like I was thinking me going to LA but
like every time I go to LA but it when I
get back or like I always regret going
you can't go to LA without me because
it's my favorite place I never go in LA
we have to make a week of LA no I know I
just like like doing like little trips
to LA cuz like I feel really famous in
LA and I just like need it I need like a
little bit of like a boost in confidence
yeah maybe if you moved there for six
months like you would feel amazing maybe
but maybe not
I just feel like LA has such good coffee
and like you know where has disgusting
coffee new york new york city new york
city you had like why is New York known
for its coffee I didn't get arrested
here for a cup of coffee
that was good what are they talking
about when they talk about New York
coffee do they talk about it they turn
in pizza in New York baby maybe they
don't they don't talk about coffee I
feel like la coffee are you like Dallas
coffee I got a simple girl when it comes
to coffee and I think that if you
actually went to like those carts like
the halal carts like the and those blue
cups that are like so iconic New York I
actually think you might like it okay
I'm gonna try it
you should go I'm like a coffee tour of
New York cuz you guys have really been
struggling in our new studio to get
location was I'm kind of over the Keurig
machine I use one at home but every day
I just like I hate drink it I'm so glad
that you made this by one and a limited
yeah nobody's is that no but it's like
nice to be able to offer someone a cup
of coffee remember that time you know
those before there's my favorite story
about Claudia I did uh you had like you
were doing a shoot we embed did this
series for snapchat they wanted to film
in our house so we did him and like a
whole crew my hair and makeup and like
does anybody want anything like water
just moved into like your first like
really nice apartment and you wanted to
be like the house where there's
everything and I had everything I had
chargers like I really wanted to be the
house that like everyone could come over
and no one would have to leave because
like you need to change of underwear I
got you
yeah you any drinks that you want like
it's just great to be that house yeah I
have like soda Snapple water seltzer
fresca everything and I was offering
everyone my drinks and a couple like
maybe that some of the hair makeup
people were like yeah we'll take a
coffee and I was like yeah okay I'm like
I don't have coffee how do you how do
you make coffee I don't I mean I don't
drink coffee and I guess like you put a
um pot I literally don't use a coffee
machine yeah I don't have that I never
have I just made me have to be there no
yeah you definitely didn't have to be
there okay next right we have a lot to
talk about takers we sell chocolate oh
yeah pearls Gabrielle Union introduces
twelve-year-old Ziya to the world quote
she's whip-smart
and we are so proud on Tuesday Gabrielle
Union shared a series of heartwarming
tweets raving over her husband Dwyane
Wade's daughter
Ziya quote meet saya she's compassionate
loving whip-smart and we are so proud of
her Union wrote alongside a video of
Ziya who can be heard stressing the
importance of being true to yourself
quote it's okay to listen to love and
respect your children exactly as they
are
love and light good people so this is so
sweet
Dwyane Wade was on Ellen yes that's how
I heard about it oh I saw the tweets
even though I followed Gabrielle Union
on Twitter and I don't know why I
wouldn't have seen this but I saw an
Ellen the way he was speaking about how
I think it's his child from a former
marriage Gabrielle Union is not his
biological biological woman clear yeah
Dwyane Wade's daughter so I saw him
speaking about it on Ellen and I thought
it was so sweet like I feel like this is
like new territory for like a lot of
parents and I think that like this is a
shining example of how you just like
embrace your kids coming out as
themselves yeah it's really beautiful
he said me and my wife Gabrielle Union
are proud parents of a child in the
lgbtq+ community and we are proud allies
as well we take our roles in our
responsibility responsibility as parents
very seriously so when our child comes
home with a question when a child comes
home with an issue when a child comes
home with anything it's our job as
parents to listen to that to give them
the best information that we can to give
them the best feedback that we can and
that doesn't change because sexuality is
now involved in it totally I think that
this was like so I was like getting
choked up watching The Ellen thing I
just thought it was so great I have seen
on both Gabrielle unions and Dwyane
Wade's Instagram pictures of their
family and people say the meanest word
like saying the meanest things about
their former son he was like wearing
crop tops and he was so cute and like so
like himself and Dwyane Wade and
Gabrielle Union like never waved in
their defense of him and like we're
always standing up for him and I would
just thought it was like so cool you
know you don't see that every day
and so I just think that this is great -
really beautiful they're a beautiful
family and yeah I actually have
absolutely literally like gun to my head
we have no choice yeah none none
whatsoever but but to stand and also
their younger baby is the cutest little
baby I've ever seen in my life so
they're just they've got it all going on
and I'm I'm quite happy for them yes me
too okay didn't find a story speaking of
coffee and your caffeine fix Pepsi's new
product has nearly twice as much
caffeine as its regular soda thank God
but Mike its rival Coke Pepsi is
launching a new coffee infused Cola you
guys oh my god what I have to do that
okay I could use Diet Coke with more
caffeine me too but here's my logistical
question obviously this is something
people want because Pepsi and Coke are
the biggest brands in the world and they
didn't not do mark it's a chocolate
hummus like somebody wants it but when
am I supposed to drink this I drink
coffee in the morning but why would I'm
not gonna drink soda first thing in the
morning you brought your teeth I'm gonna
wait till 3 o'clock yeah I know that
like there's probably someone who's
looking forward to this but I just have
to say this is a product that nobody
needs and while you know Pepsi and Cola
are in their labs like making new
formulas I would really really love and
appreciate a diet coke with caffeine
that actually has caffeine like I know
some people like Ben's mom like if we're
out to dinner she loves Diet Coke but
she won't have to add coke at dinner
because she won't be able to fall asleep
I'm like what are you talking about like
I can live at I cook at midnight and
fall asleep at 12:01 I just can't relate
so I could really use they need caffeine
free diet coke regular diet coke with
caffeine and then die coke with actual
caffeine well I mean the diet coke with
caffeine is 70 milligrams like that's
it's nothing I've never felt more awake
because of a diet coke in my life maybe
because you drink too much and I've
never been able to not sleep because I
had a diet coke recently yeah like I
wouldn't even know I wouldn't have no
idea that died coke had caffeine if
somebody hadn't told me that a few years
ago like it's just and I know that used
to be like gold and silver guy coke like
silver doesn't have Kevin it's all and
you feel like that no I know but like
literally they're the same to me
interesting well I'll try it because I'm
on this journey to try every coffee in
America yeah that you know where has the
best where's the best coffee you've ever
had oh yeah hi Boris right by camcos
tickets are sold out sorry should we do
that apparels
yes okay I had a really interesting time
watching Vanderpump rules cuz I watched
it
later and Sheena was live-tweeting and I
found it really interesting to see how
she defended her abhorrent behavior and
you know what oh I can't what she didn't
she literally was responding to people
being like you're so embarrassing she's
like I know I was like in a really bad
spot like she does that every season I
know but no one will see I have to
respect someone who publicly like owns
their [ __ ] and doesn't defend poor
behavior well I think when watching it
back like her behaviors indefensible
yeah at least like yeah she's smart
enough to know that she's not gonna like
defend that but next season's gonna be
the same [ __ ] yet have literally
been like this for eight seasons where
all of her behavior like is immature
yeah and embarrassing and like there's
no growth there's no evolution no okay
so we had pride Tom Tom and sir Tom Tom
is like the shiny new toy like nobody
wants to go to sur it looked like so
dirty like I would have rather been a
Tom Tom and that's where all like pretty
saucy we're out because they didn't have
to work Lala
James T Jayde he's still drinking um was
that a custom ego sponsored cup oh I
don't think so but maybe custom ego
sponsored fries Tom Tom because they
have those cups right just use those
cups Taunton is really like for the
alumni yeah and sir it's for the
freshmen totally
they were both behind the bar Tom and
Tom Jax was bartending oh the suspended
manager like literally running around
start telling Jax just head up at the
bar like I know everyone probably
thought like if you went on Twitter
everyone's like chuckle he's not gonna
help set up he's like this girl like I
totally got why he was being a dick he's
like no I don't do that like I'm
literally not even being paid to be here
like I'm here so that people will come
to Sur like I'll Sam behind the bar but
I'm not [ __ ] cutting lemons like I
actually totally understood I completely
understood him and like they were one
person down in every category when it's
like the suspended manager is it's in
the manager and it's her job to make
sure they're over staff not regular
staff and then some people don't show up
they should have every single person
working like that's on the suspended
manager no and also sir was a [ __ ] show
like where the [ __ ] was Lisa like it was
such a mess they had two bartenders what
the [ __ ] and Jax is you can't count Jax
as a bartender he's a celebrity you know
Jax is like a bar like a show pony for
prize he's a mannequin he's not there to
actually be slinging drinks so suspended
manager talking to him like I guess
technically she's the manager but
like talking to him like she was his
boss it's like girlfriend no like that's
not how this works
no that's how any of this works but the
hierarchy is so interesting because
technically the manager is above the
bartender like Jax is that's her boss
but it's like no that's not actually how
it works Helen at this event right so it
was just so funny to see like her being
like all pissy that he wasn't gonna get
back and like start prepping when it's
like that's literally not what he's here
to do no James DJed they said he did a
great job Katie being so funny me like
yeah I was actually my idea to have you
DJ I thought that was hilarious
she hear him he and Lola had a
conversation which I found to be so
interesting I had forgotten about all
that faulty stuff and I didn't realize
that James I hopped on the bandwagon to
get likes and honestly that would have
pissed me off too yeah and law was just
too forgiving no but she's so smart
because it's like she's not gonna wage
World War 3 with James like she's just
telling him like you're still not grown
you can't be friends I can't wait around
for you I wish you the best right like
she gave him the chance yeah no but
she's being so mature about it yeah she
looked sickening and I think also for
her to be sober and then be friends with
someone whose behavior is so up and down
due to alcohol like it must be difficult
for her yeah um I actually like you know
who's growing on me in the last like
three seasons more than any other person
on the show is Ariana like she's not I
was on the right side of his straight
when it comes to like Tom and like the
drama but I just really like her and I
thought it was like kind of cuter she
was like getting all like email about
the fact that her first pride being like
openly blocked by and she brought her
little by flag and I just liked her yeah
I like her too she's like the president
woke person yeah she seems like a good
human yeah and when she's in her own
situations like I do enjoy her story but
sometimes she like with Tom Sandoval
who's Madonna apparently yeah it's he by
the way he's out of control and his ego
is so big like it's really affecting
like the show and he brings her down a
little bit to me Tom Sandoval is like
really nothing of the sort he's a cast
member you know he's been there from the
beginning but the success of the show
has very little to do with him right and
so for him to like think that he is
Marilyn Monroe yeah it's just
Marilyn sound of all it's nothing of
this sort no he's the definition of Tom
Monroe you know what
you know it actually happened somebody
lied to him yeah and told him that he
was really like the protagonist of the
show and like he put the whole show on
and he's nothing like that he's
literally I think I'm the sort when like
Tom Schwartz is the perfect example of
how you should behave like he loves it
he feels like a rock star he's having
fun but like he's not it's not going to
his head he doesn't take it too
seriously like how many times was Tom
said of all gonna literally stop the
pride party to make an announcement that
he was so glad everyone could come oh my
god more than one many so unnecessary um
did not show up for her sir
Oh thing I know that like it's so easy
to hate on Raquel um and she should have
shown up but I thought that the way that
she reacted to please exactly how your
act like if it was James he would've
been like oh they just told me not to
come yeah but mark I was like I work all
night I just I feel like she was really
sorry Jackie I agree I do think she
missed it on purpose but I think when
you're talking to your boss she had
respect she was apologetic I totally
agree she she owned it she but in my
book she totally lost me last night when
she kicked Dana out of the hair
appointment like what you're gonna
succumb to Cena's demands here's the
thing I I agree and what she never
really had me so I didn't expect
mindless but she is someone who is like
teetering on the edge of being on this
show it's really Sheena show when it
comes to the freshmen now and whatever
Sheena says goes for her because she's a
follower I don't for sure vector to be
Leo she's a follower and that was
disappointing yeah because I love Dana
I'm eight I love Dean and that
conversation in the back alley was
everything are you 35 or are you 16 yeah
and she says don't just talk about it be
about it
you know she wouldn't let her off like
she then just kept like giving these
[ __ ] excuses and Tina wouldn't let
the conversation and it's like until
Sheena was broke down crying right and
she was gonna do better right like this
this conversation was the culmination of
a bunch of [ __ ] and Sheena thought
she could get away with it just being
like you know like so you know my
friends like I got territory Oh like I'm
really sorry like that's not enough
Sheena it's not [ __ ] enough no not at
all and I
I'm sure Sheena is going through a tough
time I think you know life is a tough
time it is but they're open up and share
with us or us I can't I can't happy that
and they're having really tough times
that she's been going through and also
Dena hung out with her friends one
[ __ ] time at the comedy club like
that that one situation warrants a whole
hack when she was saying when she knows
like I'm not jealous about Max it's like
no I'm jealous about
yeah and behavior than and Max and I
think max Edina are so cute like waking
up in her apartment together like I love
them and I hope that it doesn't turn out
to be like he's a fuck-boy like talking
around on her because it'll make her
look so stupid but I love them together
I don't even think would make her look
stupid like you have to be able to try
and open up guys suspended manager
ajusshi Nishino like pulling her over
and being like I'm just looking out for
you like then they could be like we
really were looking out for you you know
I just don't want them to win yeah
because I love Dana she's leather my
favorite character and you know I like
her conversation with Jax I was just
gonna say that respect me respect
she literally won him over in two
minutes
totally because she's just she's not
she's cool and she's really not trying
to like ride anyone's coattails like she
just is on the show and she wants to
make it on her own volition on her own
like being funny and cool and I think
Jax respected that because I think Jax
doesn't like all these new people coming
in just like trying to become famous off
a show where Jax is like really bled out
for like he's been the villain like I
totally get why he hates the new people
but I think he and me doesn't respect to
Dana and I didn't fault him for not
remembering her from the Monterey either
like he sat outside the whole time yeah
and I to him those were just like random
girls yeah I don't know that I would
have remembered either no me neither I
didn't even remember until she saw it he
said I thought that that was just a
little petty but it was funny
Jax barely remembers anyone anyone let
alone actual people he does not expected
her man I'm so glad you thought that was
a memorable moment because I thought
that conversation was like my two ships
coming in yeah next week looks so
interesting where it's like we're
getting into political correctness where
it's like cancel culture because we all
know what happens now but there was a
ton of backlash about Brittney and Jax's
pastor that they chose from I think it
was from Kentucky like her church he had
said some like crazy [ __ ] on Facebook
about gay people and they didn't end up
like canceling him until Lisa said
something to them and Lance Bass ended
up doing it which I thought was
hilarious I was wondering who wound up
marrying them yeah I just like can't
wait for the wedding episode because
like I need to see if I'm in the
background like Julie like an animal I
feel like they canceled that past or two
weeks before that's what they were
saying so the following week should
probably be the wedding oh my god you're
right you know we're getting close we
are how many episodes in a row
I don't know I was wondering cuz it
still feels like the season hasn't
started I know I get so lost in a
Braavos season and then all of a sudden
it
the finale and I'm like we just started
or sometimes it just drags on forever I
feel like this season of Atlanta is
dragging on so long like it started out
so strong and I can't even finish
episodes now I find Kenya to be just the
most abhorrent like she's just she's
horrible like I just I hate her no she's
just so unethical and I know that's like
weird like pull out ethics on a reality
show but everybody's aligned there's a
lot of yarra down the road but there's a
line and everything she does is just so
terrible she called Tonya who's by the
way China's most annoying person on
planet Earth but she's one of those
girls was like annoying but nice you
know like she's overwhelming with her
kindness and her like giddiness and she
just wants to be friends with everyone
shakarez seaward at lunch for pulling
out Kenya's wig out of a bag like it
just didn't Warren weren't being called
the c-word and I just think she crosses
a line and I'm really over her like
she's just she's not even that she's
nothing of the sort I wouldn't even give
her that compliment she just really not
even like part of this orange she's a
bad person like and that's crazy to say
I'm reality-tv would like nobody's
really like an angel yeah but she's a
bad person and like she tried to ruin
her friend's engagement on purpose and I
just I can't I need to talk about one
thing
scheana on that man's shoulders and then
refusing to open her legs okay and head
locking him in her thighs on the sweaty
sailors de la when this sheriff had just
carried Lisa and apparent down the
street and then put she's literally on
his back yep
I just wanted to I'm so glad you brought
that up open her life I'm so glad you
brought that up because first of all I
want to talk about that man for a second
the hero of pride like Lisa and her
broken toe nothing me not she's like an
old woman she can't walk that's why she
couldn't walk yeah and she's like a
drama queen but I thought he was so cute
like she made a joke to one of the
police officers about carrying her and
then here comes this big strong man in
the actually carried her and then he
carried scheana and he was just like an
unsung hero of the episode but when
scheana was being like Oh with the legs
with her with his head coming out of her
legs like let the man up I just wanted
to say like that's harassment
like I demanded that to a woman like Oh
Mike I would sue if I somehow found
myself in that position no but he
started to release because his face
wasn't blurred yeah no no no like I
would sue her of course that was Claudia
I terrible had to and her like giggling
looking at the camera like ooh when I
had to pause because I couldn't get over
it because it was so different
everything I've seen on reality TV that
was the most shocking thing oh great and
the sweat
terrible Hey terrible I'm Fujiyama did
your toasters yes
our advice segment please if you want
any advice from us we always keep it
anonymous tear toasters at gmail.com
Story number one
dear Claudia and Jackie as the subject
says my best friends seriously smells
the smell isn't bo but something else
the best way to describe the smell is
dirty clothes that have been sitting on
her floor that her animals have peed and
rolled around on that she doesn't wash
but she keeps wearing it's unlike
anything I've ever smelled before and I
almost gagged just typing this cuz I
feel as though I got a wolf of the
stench I first noticed when friends were
out of town visiting brought it up to me
I then started noticing when she would
get in and out of my car when she would
give me a pair of pants tomorrow and
they reek of well dirty clothes that
have been sitting on the floor while
animals peed on them and possibly [ __ ]
question is how do I tell her
can I tell her how can she not know it
was honestly it is honestly become
unbearable to the point where I can't
stand too close to her I don't want
people to think it's me that smells when
we're out together
love you both okay okay if you just
gotta be real if you're not that close
with her I would just end the friendship
but if you are close with her and you
want to make it work it's possible that
she doesn't have a sense of smell and
that's why she doesn't know we have a
friend like that who's always asking if
she smells because she can't smell we do
yeah we do will you tell me who it is
later yeah I mean it's not like and
she's always overcompensating for it
because she knows that she can smell how
interesting isn't me no okay um so I
would just if it's really not granted
like I would be straight up yeah you
gotta be dry maybe write an anonymous
letter like you have to tell this person
or else you can't be like seen with them
god forbid someone thinks that you smell
like animal piss I'd rather smell like
Bo honestly I always think okay put
myself in the position of the person
who's being told that they smell I would
be so grateful like if and we mortified
yet that I knew that I smelled for so
long but that I won't smell in the
future like maybe she doesn't know if
someone came to me and said like listen
this is a chronic intervention you know
me and you're listening to this and I
ever smell please tell me yeah one time
like cut me a break but if I if I am the
smelly friend right oh let me down and
you tell me that like I would change
everything about my life I would be so
grateful I would be over well I would be
the best mountain person you ever met
so give her that chance if she doesn't
take the bait then you know what
I think there's something wrong but like
you have to think maybe she doesn't know
I don't know how she couldn't but maybe
she's a broken nose yeah no maybe she
doesn't have a sense of smell all right
next up hi Claudia and Jackie recent
toaster I told you there are new
toasters and first-time submitter I
actually haven't seen like just found
the toast I know so I just want to want
them to feel left out when we're talking
about like weird [ __ ] okay um I need
some advice on how to approach my sister
to give a little context I got married
last year to my high school sweetheart
after planning for a year and I'd have
nowhere my sister who was my maid of
honor calls me a month before my wedding
to ask me if I will go to her elopement
in Vegas I didn't go yes I was upset but
we also couldn't afford it
so recently I found out I'm pregnant and
we're so excited but when I told
everyone she became salty that I didn't
tell her I was trying we weren't
now every time we hear news about my
sister is it about my sister it's hot
it's about how hard she is she's trying
to get pregnant now my question is am I
thinking too hard that my sister tries
to steal my thunder in life I can't seem
to get a little spotlight especially
when it came to my wedding and my first
pregnancy now how do I build a better
bond with my sister am i a jealous one
I'd love to hear about how two wonderful
sisters think love being a toaster and
love you both that's interesting sister
jealousy is so weird I think you know
seeing as how everyone is jealous of me
I'm gonna well I know seeing as how I'm
literally jealous of everyone I think I
could speak on this like better than
anyone okay
you know why you just kind of let it go
like I'm jealous of everything that
everyone has and it really ruins my like
life like I feel like I'm not happy
about the things that I have because I'm
always looking over my shoulder about
like what my friends and family have and
it's a terrible way to live so I think
that you need to just like absolve
yourself of all this jealousy whether
whether it's like you think she's
jealous
or your gel like I just think you know
what you just got a lot of go and they
think like being jealous a little bit
jealous of someone when something good
happens for him I think that's human
nature so like of course so I think it's
okay when something happens you can have
a moment of jealousy but then over like
acknowledge to yourself that you're
jealous
and then be happy for this person also
it seems like she does all these things
to get attention but it also seems like
your life is wonderful and you had a
wonderful wedding photo and you got
pregnant so unexpectedly and like you
just have all that such a privilege like
always
clamoring if stealing her thunder gives
her a little bit of happiness like let
her have it because it seems like you
have a lot Chucky's that was literally I
think to this day some of the best
advice you've ever given
thank you it's hard to not see its you
like the the girl who wrote in like
can't see that but as a third party
perspective like just the way she
describes it it seems like she this girl
really has her life together and her
sisters was kind of having a harder time
so you know give it to her the jealous
thank you you have the dream wedding and
and the pregnancy and all that happiness
and you don't also get the adoration and
the bobbum like so everyone needs a
little something and if that's what she
needs she just feel okay let her have it
that wasn't such good advice I'm Chuck
I'm okay our third and final do your
toasters so about a month ago my dad
sent me and my brother down to tell us
that when he was a medical school he
made money by being a sperm donor he
explained it as something that was
normal for guys back in the 80s they
were promised absolute anonymity when he
met my mom she asked him to stop and he
did 30 years later thanks to 23andme
these donor children have began tracking
down and messaging my extended family in
attempts to connect with their
biological father this is why my dad
finally told me in my brother he was
worried that we would find out somehow
with one of the message just on social
media
basically these companies screwed up the
whole anonymity thing that's terrible by
the way one of the donors contacted my
dad through his cousin since the donor
children grew up such live in the same
city as us she asked to meet my dad he
met up with her and they couldn't
believe how many things they had in
common and how much she looked like me
they kept in touch after their meeting
and she told my dad there were more kids
that she had found it's so weird to me
that they wanted to meet him because
they were all coming from loving
families with parents and other siblings
but I guess I just can't relate anyways
here's my question should I go with my
dad to meet some of them my brother and
I are not interested in taking it to
that level because it's all just so
weird and uncomfortable to us however I
don't want my dad to be going through
this all alone a lot of these donor
families keep in touch by creating
Facebook groups oh my god where they
post pictures of themselves as kids
compare similarities etc my dad made one
of these and the new people are slowly
rolling in and posting actively he seems
so happy to spend my brother and I
wishing that he would just chill and not
force a situation help please wow this
is like I've never felt so completed the
Vince Vaughn movie did delivery man I
know when you know what I really feel
like not enough people are talking about
how 20 like companies like 23andme are
ruining those anonymity
like clauses when you would donate sperm
and if someone was generous enough
whether they were doing it for money
whether they were generous enough to
help another couple have children like I
feel like this is so [ __ ] up like
we'll get to the how she should handle
it but like the basis of
this man not being protected anonymity
wise when he was just doing like a
charitable cause yes he was being paid
for it but like your promise that
anonymity and you don't have that
anymore like I think that's really
[ __ ] up you shouldn't be at he and his
kids she'd not have to be dealing with
us because when he signed up it was
under the pretense that this is all
completely anonymous yeah I feel like we
should have figured this out like nobody
thought of this
it's DNA it sucks it's not fair yeah
they should have to be dealing with this
no but also like these kids deserve no
you don't deserve no I do they deserve
to meet their biological father when
they come from loving parents who use
the sperm bank I don't know I don't know
either these are I've never thought
about these issues I don't have a look
imagine if we found out like our dad was
like I just can't but like I think for
us he would if we found out that we had
other people out there with our DNA and
that were you know our dad's biological
kids we would be so excited because it
would be like oh my god no I would not
be excited oh my god I would be so
excited I would be like you stole my DNA
get out of here no I want to be excited
oh I feel weird not really conflicted
but I think ultimately it would be
exciting to meet someone who's so
similar to us and like a piece of our
dad know what I feel like not alive yeah
but I feel so fulfilled with my family
like I don't need more I'm not looking
for new family members like if you
discover take people to yourself that I
do think like because this is such a big
thing in their family it's not really
something that they can ignore
especially because it makes their dad so
happy so because it makes him so happy
no do not feel obligated to go with him
and make him do it alone because he's
happy he's doing it alone just choice
he's getting a car but I think like they
need to figure out this relationship
where it's like their family members but
they're not siblings know the Facebook
group is weird but it's like a big
family reunion I don't this seemed if
this was happening all the time I I
don't know how people should handle it
but because it's like a one-off crazy
situation and it's like three identical
strangers it's like there's these people
out there who I mean in their case there
are a hundred percent you yeah and how
can you go your whole life not knowing
them
it's just freaky this is something like
I can't relate to in any way but I just
like to think like if I was in that
situation I don't think I would be so
mature no I think I would be really
conflicted on the one hand it's like no
I like my life I want to keep it this
right I don't want new
but on the other hand it's like these
people are 50% you you know how can you
turn your back to yourself I think I
could I really do and maybe you would
love them because they're so similar to
you like more Claudia Oh God hahaha no
yeah maybe it's my jealousy kicking in
but like I'm completely uninterested I
would feel I think it would be very
normal to feel like get the [ __ ] out of
my face ho and nobody asked for you
right um but when you take a big picture
look at it it's kind of a cool thing as
long as they're not like asking for
something I want to be money well yeah
right no I'm not interested but I wish
you luck in this treacherous journey an
eagle case yes biological children okay
so if you want to get some advice email
us dear toasters at gmail.com that's all
we got for you guys thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching
this on youtube please subscribe give
this video a thumbs up also follow us on
Instagram we are very close to 200 K at
the morning toes we'd really appreciate
it we post premium content multiple
times today and follow me on instagram
at Jackie O problems premium content I I
need to be posting more I make you take
a photo of me after all so make sure
you're following at the redheads book
club listen to the first episode of the
redheads start reading book number two
so you can be all caught up we are also
available as podcast and we're podcast
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public video i art radio cast
box all the places wherever you choose
to listen to podcasts find us hi it's
morning toast
leave a comment maybe five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are I don't know your cha your call
have a great day we will see you
tomorrow